ANNOUNCER: Is Carl
Kasell your friend?
Find him and other NPR
folks at npr.org/community.
ROBERT SIEGEL:
From NPR News this
is "All Things Considered."
I'm Robert Siegel, and it's time
now for All Tech Considered.
These days, you can
learn just about anything
from a YouTube video.
[PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 1: First of
all, we want to put
this bow around his neck.
[END PLAYBACK]
ROBERT SIEGEL: A
South Carolina man
teaches us how to tie a bow tie.
His YouTube video has been
viewed more than 650,000 times.
Or maybe you've always wanted
to learn how to play the piano.
[PLAYBACK]
[PIANO CHORD]
SPEAKER 2: Let's make this
thing minor, shall we?
We take the middle
finger and move it
down a half step to the F.
[PIANO CHORD]
[END PLAYBACK]
ROBERT SIEGEL: Today
on All Tech Considered,
we're going to
talk with a man who
is devoting his life to
creating YouTube tutorials.
[PLAYBACK]
SALMAN KHAN: Welcome
to the presentation
on multiplying fractions.
Today you'll be very happy
because you'll find out
that this is one of
the few times where
multiplying something is
easier than adding it.
And if you don't believe
me let's do some problems.
[END PLAYBACK]
ROBERT SIEGEL: That
is Salman Khan.
Not the Salman Khan
who's a Bollywood star.
This is the Salman Khan,
former hedge fund analyst
turned online tutor.
He has produced more than
1,000 YouTube videos, ranging
from basic multiplication
of fractions
to polynomial
approximation of functions.
And he joins us now from
Silicon Valley in California.
Welcome.
SALMAN KHAN: Thanks.
ROBERT SIEGEL: Your
channel on YouTube
is called the "Khan
Academy Channel."
Why did you decide to
become a tutor online?
SALMAN KHAN: It happened
fairly organically.
I started remotely tutoring some
of my cousins in New Orleans.
I was working, as you mentioned,
as a hedge fund analyst
in Boston at the time.
My cousin Nadia
was having trouble
placing into the
pre-algebra class.
So I talked to
Nadia a little bit.
And I said, how about you and
me do some remote tutoring
after I come home from work
and you come home from school.
We'll get a
conference call going,
and maybe we'll use
Instant Messenger
or we'll find something else.
We ended up using Yahoo Doodle.
And word got around
amongst friends and family,
and I had a little cohort
of about 10 or 15 students.
And then it just became
difficult logistically
between my work and
their soccer practice.
And I had to keep tutoring
the same lessons over and over
again depending on
how old they were,
so I decided to just record my
lessons but in the same style
that I was doing with Nadia
that seemed to be effective.
And I started just recording
them and putting them
on YouTube.
And even your or my
great-great-grandkids
could learn from
these same videos.
ROBERT SIEGEL: Now, I've
watched a few of them.
You never appear on
screen, just a mouse
arrow that draws in different
colors on a black background.
And you narrate.
How are you actually
making these?
SALMAN KHAN: When
I started, it was
literallY-- I took
Microsoft Paint, made
the background black, picked
some florescent colors,
and I used this
shareware-- I think
it was called Screen
Video Recorders,
it was a $20 piece of
software-- to capture my screen
and to record my voice
at the same time.
And that would just
produce the videos.
I just did it because
that was, I thought,
the cheapest and fastest way
to make a decent quality video.
Since then, one of
the viewers actually
donated a $300 piece
of software called
Camtasia Recorder for
the screen capture.
And now I use another piece of
shareware called Smooth Draw 2,
I think it's called.
I use that to draw.
And I just have a little
Wacom graphic pen tablet
to do the writing.
ROBERT SIEGEL: Now
let's go through some
of the range of what
you're doing tutorials
in, in mathematics and
chemistry, biology.
SALMAN KHAN: Yeah,
in the non-sciences,
there's obviously a lot
on finance and economics.
Actually, a lot of that
comes from last year
during the financial crisis.
In my hedge fund world, I
put all my money in cash
and I started reading
the Federal Reserve Act.
I read it about 10 times just
to understand all of the levers
that the Federal Reserve
Chairman could pull.
And I said, well,
what's a better
use of my time than
whatever I just learned.
Let me make a series
of YouTube videos
on fractional reserve banking
in the Federal Reserve.
And I don't plan
on limiting myself
to just the maths
and the sciences
ROBERT SIEGEL: Now
here's something
I noticed while
watching a tutorial
you were giving about stocks.
You were, I think,
making the point
that a stock that
costs $1 a share
is not necessarily cheaper than
a stock that costs $10 a share.
As I'm watching
it, a crawl comes
across the bottom from
Google directing me
to a website where
I can look over
the prospectus for
various penny stocks.
It's an advertisement, and
indeed the advertisement
is actually based
on a proposition
that you're shooting down in
the course of the tutorial.
SALMAN KHAN: [LAUGHING]
ROBERT SIEGEL: So
who's advertising?
How many of your
courses are advertised?
And how do you feel about
this kind of education
being underwritten by a sponsor?
SALMAN KHAN: The advertising
is what YouTube puts up just
by virtue of it
being on YouTube.
I do share some of the revenue.
It was pushing about $1,500 of
revenue to Khan Academy Inc,
which is a 501(c)(3)
not-for-profit organization.
So it's going to the
organization right now.
It's not coming to me as
a salary anyway right now.
ROBERT SIEGEL: Without
the advertising, are you--
I know you were working for
a hedge fund before-- but are
you-- is this self-sustaining?
Can you support this as a
career doing it based on people
free of charge
looking at videos?
SALMAN KHAN: Well right now,
it isn't self-sustaining
as of today.
I joke that it's being
funded by the Salman Khan
Bank Of America
checking account.
My wife has given me a year
to make it self-sustaining,
although I think she'll give me
a little more leeway than that.
If I get no outside
support, there
are the donations
that are coming
in from the viewers themselves.
That's bringing in
about $1,500 a month.
I have these kind of
low-key ads that you
mentioned that are
just off of YouTube.
If I were to be aggressive
with the advertising, which
I don't want to do,
I could probably
generate another few
thousand dollars a month.
And at the rate that the
viewership is growing--
it's growing at about
15% or 20% per month--
I'm reasonably confident
that in about a year the site
itself could pay my rent
and put food on the table.
ROBERT SIEGEL: Are you a faculty
of one at the Khan Academy?
SALMAN KHAN: I currently am.
There are people who have
come out of the woodworks
really in the last
two months or so
to volunteer
translating the videos.
There's a chemistry
teacher in Uruguay
who did the first translation.
There's an effort going on
to translate into Arabic,
into Polish, into
Portuguese, into German,
but right now all
of the content is
and has been generated by me.
ROBERT SIEGEL: You come
across in these videos
as a very natural teacher.
And I wonder, on the way
through MIT and Harvard Business
School and the hedge fund
trade, did you ever just
consider becoming a teacher?
SALMAN KHAN: I actually
was a teacher just
to make some extra
cash during college.
I was an MCAT instructor
for the Princeton Review
for one summer, and
I used to a volunteer
teaching middle school
kids at the Devotion
School in Brookline.
It's something that
I really enjoy,
but the economics of
the hedge fund world
were a little bit better.
ROBERT SIEGEL: You could have
done a very simple tutorial
on the difference between
the pay of a hedge fund
analyst and a teacher.
When you're teaching
online, there's
not a real-time exchange
with the students,
and their comments to you
aren't coming back in real time.
Do you think that would be
an added virtue of education,
or does it matter that much?
SALMAN KHAN: I
think that this is
an advantage I have over
a traditional teacher,
just from my limited
experience from teaching live.
One of the hardest
things is to sit
in front of a classroom
of 20 to 30 students,
and maybe five of them are
giving you a nice attentive
expression and the rest
of them have blank faces.
You don't know if they're bored
or they're falling behind.
It makes you insecure and you
don't know what to do next.
But I go to my computer,
spend 10 minutes,
explain something as I would
explain it to you or my cousin,
and then I upload it on YouTube.
The whole process takes
maybe half an hour.
And within an hour of
putting up a video,
a few hundred people
will watch it.
And I wait for them to give
that YouTube five-star rating
and put a couple of comments up
saying, oh, this is so great.
I was going to fail this class.
Now I'm going to pass the
exam tomorrow, whatever else.
So I wait for that
feedback, and that gives me
the confidence to keep going.
ROBERT SIEGEL: Salman Khan, who
teaches math, science, finance,
and much more at
khanacademy.org.
Thank you very much
for talking with us.
SALMAN KHAN: Thank
you very much.